Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two David Pakman.
This is a really important topic. I got
a caller who said, is there something
about the news that is bad for one's health?
Speaker 7: Hi, David. My name is Anna, long time
viewer of the show. I wanted to bring some female
representation to your voice, your questions. My
question for you is, how do you protect your
mental health while consuming so much horrible
media? Yep. Like, I, I feel like my mental
health has suffered just from trying to follow
the world's news and follow current events. And
I can't imagine what it's like for somebody that,
you know, does this as their
job. So I was wondering how
Speaker 1: how you deal with that. Yeah, many
people ask me this, so there's two things that
go on. One is, I'll admit it, you become sort
of desensitized to it. I am deaf. I know when
I'm talking to people not in this business, they
will report to me or they will mention some story
in the news. And I can tell I'm not having the
visceral reaction they're having because I've
been desensitized to a lot of the stuff. That's
number one. But number two, you've got to schedule
breaks. And when when I'm done producing Friday's
show, until I start getting ready for the Monday
show, I'm not paying attention to any news unless
there's like some weekend political event going on
that I'm involved in streaming or whatever the
case may be. And I'm just reading not politics,
reading history, science, whatever fiction
and doing other things. And I think it's of
incredible importance to do that. So the mere
fact, Ana, that you're asking the question is
a very, very good sign. We've got a great bonus
show coming up for you today. Sign up at Join
Pakman Dotcom to get instant access
Unidentified: to the bonus.